Wait, can you hear him?
Okay, I
think you can hear him for a second.
What was that sound?
That's our tour guide setting up at the moment.
Oh my god, the camera is so shaky.
Hi, hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
What was I going to say?
I was going to say welcome.
I don't have the camera up just yet because he was getting...
ready but um yeah uh this is gonna be a tour a ghost tour we did a tour before of the USS Hornet and this time is like a spooky tour of the USS Hornet so I'm especially excited and yes it's the same guide as before uh Gabe Jeff so um but I'll let him introduce himself and It's going to be a fun time.
If you guys have any questions or anything about boat, about boat, feel free to ask or ghost.
I'll answer to my best ability.
So, yeah.
I don't know if he's ready or not.
I'm just going to unmute and see how he's doing.
See if you can, okay.
I'm great.
I'm gonna do the window now, too.
Oh.
We're on boat.
Boat goes bintan?
Yes.
Cool.
Hello?
I love the walls.
They're like...
I hate this!
Oh my god.
Noseferatu?
Wait.
And the lights will flicker on and off.
Oh wait, I don't know where the light switch is.
Anyways.
Okay, good bit.
Dismissed.
Hi.
Welcome back.
I'm back!
You are back.
We can't escape.
You're haunting this place at this point.
I know.
You should just start including me.
actually could I like put up a QR code to my channel like you could say here's a ghost that haunts this ship you can subscribe to her channel here you know you know it and put it here the exit so that way now hey hey sub sub to this Minto hey use code boomer for 10% off your gamer subs right or there people get their gamer subs support the museum support news get win-win win-win he knows Guys,
do you want to introduce yourself again to anybody who didn't meet you before?
Okay, well, Miss Mint, it's great to see you again.
My name is Gable Cherry.
I'm the marketing manager here at the USS Hart Sea Air in Space Museum.
We have done this tour before.
Yeah.
Some of you may know me as...
Say it.
You want to say it?
Jeff!
I, the return of Jeff Gabe is upon us here.
This is truly a sign of the end times when Jeff Gabriel reemerges.
Jeff Gabe's here.
Well, it's kind of like the great pumpkin from Charlie Brown.
He will rise from beyond the ashes emerging out.
It's Jeff Gabe, Charlie Brown.
See, there you go.
It's a Jeff Gabe, Charlie Brown.
There you go.
Hey, that's the next Yellow Brown Christmas special right there.
It's a Jeff Gabe, Charlie Brown.
Yeah, it could be all, actually, it should be for every holiday.
Let's see.
There you go.
See, Jeff gave Valentine's, Jeff gave Kwanzaa, Jeff gave Leaf Erickson Day.
You know what Leaf Erickson Day?
You're all sponge-bobbed out tonight.
Listen, listen.
You don't understand the joy and the passion behind the people who celebrate Leaf Erickson Day.
Hinga dinga der again.
Oh, my God.
Leaf Erickson Day.
But anyways.
Smith is so glad that it's I'm just so glad to have you back man it is great you realize it's almost been almost an entire year since we did that tour wait no way that's crazy that is crazy our prior conversation we're talking about how 2019 was like six years ago okay we did I okay we had a conversation we were talking about ace combat and I was like oh ace combat seven was from 2019 and I was like that's only six years ago the old yet boomers Jesus.
Who here remembers Red Mountain Dew gamer juice.
That's before we had gamer subs.
Wait, I don't even know that.
You didn't, wow, you didn't even know about, you didn't know about Red Mountain Dew and Doritos and Halo 3 and how that was just gaming code.
That's awesome.
It's radical.
Open your gaming juice to take a swig gamers.
Code red.
Oh, exactly.
There you go.
See, see.
We, Ms. Smith, we love the red.
dye here.
We love the red dye.
We consume it.
We just embody it.
I wonder what your insides look like.
Really messed up.
Wasn't there something that they had to stop selling because it was turning people's insides like purple or something?
What is it?
Like pretty patties from SpongeBob or something?
They turned my insides purple.
Yeah, yeah.
See, there you go.
See, they were selling pretty patties.
That's what they were doing the whole time.
Yeah.
Probably.
But, Ms. Mitt, we are back aboard the USS Hornet Senior Space Museum.
However, this time, a little bit more.
But, but, I will say, the USS Hornet, while has a astounding career behind her in World War II, Korea and Vietnam, She also has an astounding backstory of paranormal activity.
One of the things we do here aboard the ship is our history, mystery investigations.
People can come here to stay the night and do overnight ghost tours and investigations with paranormal experts.
Wait, overnight!
Yes, ma'am.
You guys are the QR code.
I am not a paranormal expert.
I am simply somebody who has seen some shizz.
Wait, it's okay, I am a paranormal expert.
i mean you're a ghost exactly i have to be matter of fact i have a question for you miss minn yeah hold up hold up let me let me do this hold on ready for this okay hey can a low come up in your crib
what can a low come up in your crib
what and ah don't hate on me because i'm beautiful maybe you got rid of that haircut maybe Casper will call you back.
Nah, better yet, maybe the flying dustman from SpongeBob will call you back.
Go, Steve.
I don't know the bit!
Oh, bye!
Bye, Jeff!
Okay, guys, I'm gonna do the tour now.
Oh.
For now.
Yeah, make sure to clip that.
Sorry.
But flying Dutchman and Casper ain't got nothing on Miss Smith, everyone.
It's true.
Yeah.
I didn't know.
But Miss Smith, we're about to go to some areas that you may have seen last time or haven't seen.
But we're going to go to where the highest paranormal activity areas are.
Yeah.
Right here.
I'm right here.
I know I got the EMF.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Okay.
What's that look for?
What are you judging?
in huh i'm an emf 5 out of 5.
oh gosh you're gonna turn my chat parasocial to you they're gonna be like wow this is too close hey chat how you doing huh you're doing stop stealing them from me i ain't stealing nothing you know what i mean i'm jeff gave you know what i mean i'm thomas zuko you know what i mean i'm greece flagging it i'm the Rizzler.
Oh, gosh.
Everybody's...
Let's not do that.
Otherwise, we're going to see the Rizzler and we're going to see the Costco guys show up.
And the last thing I need is to see the demons of Costco show up here.
Saying like, hey, five big booms.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Yeah, that would be actually...
I can't believe there's not like a horror game based off of like them yet.
Like an indie horror game in the distance.
You hear boom, boom.
Five nights at Costco.
Five booms at Costco.
You're boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Well, anyways, welcome back, everyone.
Whoa.
It's spooky.
It's dark.
All right, Miss Mint, let's start off.
Does anybody have any questions?
We're back in action.
Anybody have any questions about the ship with paranormal activity here?
And I got one ghost story from my own experience that we'll talk about when we get to that location does anyone have any questions that does not revolve around five nights of Freddy's this is not about five nights of Freddy's someone asked if there's any snacks on this tour unfortunately I ate them all because I got big back big back big back big back man my back is loaded up with snacks
Don't make me regret accepting this tour from you.
I think you already have.
I randomly hit up, man.
I'm like, hey, I'm doing all these ghost tours.
I did the tour of Miss Lisa and Pippa.
I'm like, they're actually asking this minute.
And then she's like, heck yeah, I'm like, are you sure?
You might regret it.
I know.
I feel like you're more on hinge than before.
That was called the influence of the, hey, you influenced me.
You were like the second ever tour that I did here on the ship.
So, you know, it's just all downhill from there.
You were so polite.
Oh, my gosh.
It's actually what happens to every VTuber.
They start out so polite and so kind and sweet.
And then they just devolve into degeneracy.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Actually, no.
Corrupted.
All right, folks.
We're headed down.
Watch your step.
So, my last...
Let the lights on.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
That's the sound of the bees.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, bother.
Wait, do you hear that?
What?
The ghost of Obear saying, oh, bother, I'm so stuffed with fluff.
I'm dummy sick.
I don't think he says that ever.
And the sound and the clap of my butt cheeks alerted the bees.
Anyway.
We're crossing memes now.
We're transcending memes.
Yeah.
This is the USS Hornet's channel.
chapels.
This is where different religious ceremonies will be conducted, funerals as such.
And if you come here at a certain hour, the 11th hour of the day, sometimes you're called the chapel.
Do you hear it, Chot?
Do you hear it?
Wait, they would do funerals in here?
They would do funerals services here or they would do it up on the hangar deck and typically those bodies would be cast out at sea.
I like this like Resident Evil POV we're getting.
I know.
Then again, I'm wearing the midwifery of it.
Wearing the woofah?
Wearing the thick of it, Miss Smith.
we're headed to the cpo mess she's in the opposite mess right
there spooky
all right we're headed into our first haunted area oh my gosh i feel it i feel it
ghosts i brought you a ghost to commune with hold on let me give my best way fail.
All right.
I gotta close the door.
Oh, okay.
It doesn't work unless you have complete silence with them.
Or someone.
As quiet as a VTuber can be.
Yop, yop, yop, yop, yop.
Did he freeze?
Is it too...
Oh, there we go.
Can you hear us?
Yep.
Spirits.
Are you here?
Yes.
mean you no harm are you sure my psychic damage brought you a friend whoa what was that I don't know whoa you ever nap in these I want to trust this is the enlisted birthing area this is where they would live and they would rest and no do not make that joke chat okay this has made plenty of times birthing on a ship means sleeping area okay no my chat wouldn't say that they're too they're very mature mint mint i saw the tour last time when i was talking about the little resting gear cable little uh not cable the um torsion bar thing Yeah.
And they were making the pee pee jokes.
Yeah.
Guys, look at this reputation you've created for yourselves.
So these are foot lockers.
Even to this day sailors, they keep their entire belongings in these lockers.
These are their uniforms, their shoes, personal effects, toothbrush, etc.
Your entire life for almost eight to almost 10 months is in this locker.
the feet the what in the foot locker yes foot locker why are you talking about feet man oh man this door is off to a great start you can't have you have you have you have two feet
oh what
cameraman understood Oh my gosh, why are you doing the fire like this?
Wow!
There's a mysterious light.
What is that?
What
is that?
Oh, it's an outlet.
Oh.
Oh, that's handy.
You know, because Ghost got to be able to charge up their phones to play, you know, Azure Lane, Conkale, all that.
Yeah, obviously.
And play League of Legends.
Nope, not doing that.
Oh, sorry, sorry, not League of Legends.
Basically, you know, Ghost, they had the power outlets here because they like to play mobile games, especially the top mobile game known as Rage Shadow Legends.
You can use 70 plus champions to be able to play...
Oh, no.
Oh, we lost connection.
yeah thank god right
i could lay on that bed and then it would be you know occupied by a ghost that is true i'll just take a nap here on stream everybody the hornet haunted by mento oh yeah
see miss mitt feels at home right now when i was doing with this miss lisa man we were we were seeing some stuff man we were seeing crazy wait what were you seeing shrouded figures they're too scared of me i have too high of a power level i think what your power level yeah it's over 9 000 it's like way higher like way higher it looks like a power level like one dude okay that's a high power level I believe it.
I believe it.
Okay.
So spirits stay there.
Ah, follow us spirits.
Come this way.
Restricted area, huh?
How often are like the lights off in this place?
Pretty much all the time.
Oh.
Oh, these are the really old room.
This is...
Oh, be careful.
Oh,
the ghosts come here if it says restricted.
Oh my gosh!
Why?
It's a haunted air conditioner!
Oh, God.
Are
you spooked out, everybody?
Miss Mint.
Can't tell you something.
I'm scared right now.
Miss Mint.
What?
Dead people.
I feel like you're going to turn a corner and see like a skeleton.
I actually feel like I'm watching like a found footage.
thing guys guys use coke boomer for 10 off your gamer subs and then he was never heard from again and that was the end of jeff game he liked to play finesse
this is so unhinged are there any questions Any questions, anybody?
Any questions, anybody?
Ooh.
Is this the bathroom?
It's Skibity toilet.
Oh, man.
Boo!
End the tour!
Oh my god.
What?
Let's see.
I'm looking.
See this question?
Higher visibility.
What is it?
Oh.
Someone said, Jeff.
get evp here ever get what you know what evp is what evp electronic voice phenomenon uh you know there has been some cases of that um i know there have been different apparitions that have appeared and there have been different cases like for example i have a story where i actually heard someone calling my name down below decks and this was when i first came aboard the ship I'm not actually joking this time.
This actually happened.
It freaked me out pretty hard.
That's freaky.
Wait, so nobody was there?
Nope.
How'd they know your name?
They looked at my MySpace page.
Oh, gosh.
You're aging yourself.
I've been six years old, dude.
Come on.
Not the MySpace.
MySpace page.
Hey, you tell me you didn't have the MySpace?
You didn't have the MySpace because you're the dark kid with their MySpace and their voice of face.
Would you put me in your top friends or whatever it was called?
I might.
Woo-hoo!
Yeah, what name did they use?
Jeff or Gibb?
It's flawed.
Yeah, I'm just going to say, my name is Jeff.
We can call the game.
Another restricted area.
I'll venture deeper into the battles.
Okay.
We're going in, everybody.
Hold on.
Yeah, what deck are we on?
We are on the fourth deck.
Not many people come down here.
We used to use this area as a classroom, but it was abandoned.
We are staying here.
Yes.
We are all visiting.
There was a face.
What did you guys see?
What is that?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
You know who it is?
Is that your first Sona?
My what?
Your first Sona?
My first Sona?
Oh no.
You know, it's four's over.
Bye everyone.
Oh, that's what did it in.
Okay.
I can't tell what it is.
Oh, it's like a- It's an angel demo, clearly.
Oh, I see it now.
Oh, oh, he's so naughty!
Look at his face!
The persona of Austin Powers.
Yeah, yeah, he's doing a great impression.
Yeah, baby!
Oh my gosh!
Does kind of look like Robbie Rotten.
Robbie Rotten!
We are number one!
We got number one.
Oh no.
We triggered something.
So if people spend the night here for like ghost tours, are they allowed in these areas or no, because they're still restricted?
Well, they go in these areas, but yeah, no longer in use.
Oh.
So immersive.
Get some of the red lights around here.
Oh, Redmond's scary.
Well, it's fine.
I love red.
I love red dye.
I love red taste.
We know.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This really looks like like a FMV of a horror game or something.
It's crazy.
It's a, it's a five foot nighttime phrase, uh, prequel.
Oh my gosh.
The most horrifying place ever.
The dentist.
Oh gosh.
Wait, I haven't gotten my teeth cleaned in so long.
not since i died a fun fact for everybody at home if you go watch very odd parents the dentist is voiced by gilbert godfrey truly horrified oh boy
oh my god what the torture device this
is probably real horror for some of you guys
i think because we're deep we're deep in guys sometimes the connection is i feel like i should be putting on some spooky music for some some some ambiance give me a second i'll do that while the while we get the video back let's see spooky bejam
Creepy.
Oh.
We're back!
Not gonna lie.
We saw a bunch of human teeth in there.
What?
We missed it!
Yeah, you did.
Because Wi-Fi sucks.
Oh, can you bring us some back for us?
You want me to hold human teeth in my hand?
That's the stuff thing!
Father clean.
Nospiratu, can you hear us?
Nospiratu.
This is a model of the USS Essex.
And this meant last time you were here, we talked about how the Hornet is an Essex-class aircraft air.
That means it's a sister ship to the USS Essex.
It's the same design.
However, there are a little bit of differences with each iteration of the ships.
But this is what she looked like during World War II.
Wow.
Very long.
Wait, no.
You know, I gotta be really careful.
Your clippers are wild.
What?
Not really.
Okay.
We got the buzz going.
Alright.
Which way are we going this minute?
Going down this way.
the scary hallway scary hallway scary oh see that what was that there's a figure down the hall that way is there
oh here let's go off can you hear us
caravan down the hall can you hear us
yes wait Wait, hold on.
I want to save before I go into that room.
Oh gosh, real jump scare.
Welcome to Five Nights at Hornets.
Oh geez.
I didn't sign up for this map.
We just have less pizza.
Ooh, that was the only perk!
Ow.
I guess I deserved that.
See, after those are getting back, we need to scare in there.
listen are
there any questions any questions anybody
i don't like that laugh what's what's going on i mean i probably shouldn't read that super chat to you what what what what what i'm a big boy i can hear it someone said it's the ghost of semen anyways continuing on
on with the tour someone asked are there any areas of the ship that are permanently sealed for whatever reason there are areas that are permanently sealed because they're not fully restored in danger
see that what is that an arm an arm an arm an arm!
Oh, creepy!
It's the spirit of the postman.
Hang on, wait a minute, Mr. Postman.
Is he there?
Is he gonna wave at us?
Wait, Miss Mint, we have to do the chant to summon the ghost of the mailman.
What's that?
You hear that?
No?
No.
The ship just started creaking.
Wait, we gotta do the chant.
Ready?
Mail call, mail call, mail call, mail call, mail call.
Oh, it's the mail.
I love the mail.
I gotta go and get the mail.
I love to get the mail.
Yeah,
I watched Nickelodeon as a kid.
yeah I think a lot of people did there he is oh my gosh hello handsome hi man it's manny the mailman man geez man you're not gonna say hi to miss mint don't be such a stiff oh gosh what if we come back and he's turned like a different direction nah he wouldn't do that he's kind of stale okay I guess you could say he's fixed in his position.
I see.
I guess you could say he's stuck in place.
He's gonna move.
It happens in every video game.
And video games imitates art imitates real life.
Oh.
Oh, God.
And we're watching.
And we're moving.
Turn on.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Wait, we lost flashlight?
We lost flashlight.
Hold on.
You know, ghosts take energy from electronics to feed themselves?
Jeez, I didn't think, I did not think the male chant would work.
Oh.
Okay.
What was that?
I don't think we should go down there.
I don't know if we should.
Actually, we should.
Oh, I'm stoop.
I want to get the puck out of here, man.
Just like the hockey sticks.
Oh,
I'm so excited.
Wait, that was so spooky.
Oh, Raggy.
We need to go inside.
Oh.
They liked my...
my scooby impression you do got a good scooby impression oh thanks all right quick question the original scooby-doo theme or the the simple plan version which is the simple plan version yeah the taste mental you got a good taste this way left or right um
left and we're walking And we'll wait man.
I'm not scared.
Yeah, we just sing the song that mom told me when I'm not trying to be scared.
Uh-huh.
Ready for this?
I'm going on a bear hunt.
And don't remember that song.
Okay, first.
I don't think I know that one.
Yeah, you probably know this one though.
We're on a bear hunt.
the babyhood.
I don't think we don't know how to weed, eat them out.
Oh, I don't think I know that one either.
We never watched the SpongeBob movie.
Oh.
Oh, I guess I have.
There's a reason it's restricted.
We're going to find out here.
Really?
Where were those bumps coming from earlier?
This one's trying to figure out.
Oh.
and let me close and stop
are there any spooky questions any spooky questions anybody
sorry if i'm missing some of your guys's questions
does anyone ever sneak onto the boat no that's Crazy.
Let's let people do that.
Most popular ghost.
Uh, that would be Fred.
Fred?
Yep.
Are we gonna meet him?
Uh, you know, Fred is probably just hanging around here.
We already summoned the male ghost.
Yeah.
So we're not the accession.
What's what's special about Fred?
Fred died at sea no one knows his last name he wanders the holes of a hornet poor guy somebody who discovers his identity
all right this is where I had my paranormal experience before that's pretty freaky Wait, so you heard the voice from down there?
Over, yep, over by the freezing.
When we get to the area, I'll tell you the story, okay?
Whoa, we're going in, everybody.
Okay.
how common is it for people to encounter paranormal on the hornet it's pretty common it happens just about every ghost tour that's happened for an investigation oh that's active
this is an emergency operating area that leads to the enlisted mess deck so the toe imagine going to get some food while someone's getting surgery.
Oh!
That would enhance my appetite.
The scariest thing is the is the fire alarm beeping.
This is true.
That is the scary, the most horror-filled part.
Oh my gosh, what if we saw a shadow cross at the end of the hallway?
Wee!
Wait,
why are we first?
Because I'm not going in there alone.
Wait, so you heard your name being called from a place close to where they did surgery?
Very much.
One moment, while I turn this light off.
Okay.
To answer your questions while you're waiting.
I'm not trying to smash that button.
So dark.
Come on in, this is the machine shop.
This is where they were prepared for questions.
In-house.
Engineers love this area.
Who loves this area?
Basically, it's a big tool shop.
Engineers.
Oh, of course.
now may have people lost a limb or two down here oh yeah probably right a finger
man this man you are not scared by a lot of this you are into this you are into this this is this is my thing i was with marisa if you were feeling this this is your thing i should have known you feel right at home while we're in the midst of danger
see some ghosts that come out of the Ark of the Covenant from Indiana Jones.
That's gonna be wild, man.
Oh, that would be crazy.
Nah, listen, man.
Indiana Jones used to scare me when I was a kid.
I was scared of Indiana Jones movies so much that Lego Indiana Jones freaked me out.
No way.
That's supposed to be...
I was a kid and I watched Temple of Doom.
Okay, I can understand that.
That movie would freak me out too.
I was traumatized.
But you know, there's a lot of stuff that didn't freak me out as much.
The ending of that, the whole movie is fine until the end, I think.
I think the end was really that shock horror.
Wow, so shiny.
This is the enlisted Vestek.
This is where sailors will come and get Chow while the road...
Watch.
I remember this area, I think.
Yeah, I think we saw it last time.
Alrighty, we're entering the area the incident happened.
Congrats, I'm relieving my trauma for mental content.
Yay!
Yippee!
All right.
Freezer.
So, when I first came aboard the ship, my boss wanted me to come down here to the freezer and get a flat of water she was keeping here.
now this was just the storage area doesn't work anymore but keeps it relatively cool since it's down below debt now I come down here I wander around to a bit and I find myself here you don't know where all the light switches are so it's dark get the key undoing the lock okay let me get inside then I hear Gabe and I look over to my right I don't see anything I'm like um so I'm like hey Izzy is that you I look back and there's an over-the-distance where that doors,
there's a shrouded figure.
So I go back to my tank and I'm just like, hey, who's that?
I'm like, okay, geez, so I look around again, it's not there.
I walk in the theater and there's a freezer.
I open it up, get the waters, right?
A lot of waters.
I got it.
It's a long guy.
I look back, the figures are a little closer to where those soap hangers are.
I'm like, Okay, I'm gonna go.
Turn the corner over here.
I look back.
It's gone.
I turn up the corner again, I go in this room.
As soon as I enter this room, I hear, Dave.
And then I look back.
Nothing was there.
And to this day, I still don't know what that situation was, but I do know.
not come down to the mess deck unless you got somebody with you oh i got chills creepy
how long ago was this so it was four years ago when i first came aboard four years haven't had that experience since but hadn't had some other things other things
Someone said, now I get why my grandfather didn't talk about his time on the USS Hornet.
Oh, that's just because his favorite t-shirt was in the stock.
It is.
Oh.
Do you have any other staff member ghost experiences?
One staff member, a turner of a cult story, had an experience with an apparition.
A full apparition.
He was just at the mall, and he said, saw an apparition appear or that's
all that is all i really know oh no i'm anti-climactic but he just said he saw a guy in full dress uniform he had a lucid conversation a uniform a uniform yep full dressed white uniform oh this is the dishwasher even Oh gosh, chores are so scary.
Oh, you see something?
It just turned on.
Spirits, if you can hear us, we mean you no harm.
We are only visiting.
I mean harm.
Oh my god.
We don't see Mike, but she's like in the ghosty dimension right now.
We're here.
We're in risk.
Demons, come possess me.
Bees mischief.
Demons, scratch Gabe.
Huh?
Scratch me.
Because that's what they do.
I don't want to be scratched.
Unless it's cat scratch.
You could take it.
I get, I get, you're a cat scratch.
You don't know what cat scratch is, search it up on YouTube.
Catch, cat, cat scratch.
That was my favorite Nickelodeon show.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Cat scratch.
It's George Poplin, Mr. Blink, and I.
We're headed to our next part.
Let's go!
Haunted Bakery.
Ooh, yummy.
We got some extra thick ghosts in there.
I was going to say...
Some people call me the haunted bakery.
Why?
Keep going.
I'm excited.
Okay, okay.
Nobody's ever called me that.
Oh my gosh.
This tour is going in a direction that I don't think my boss will be too crowded before.
Sorry, camera person, for having to hear all of this.
It's okay.
You've done worse.
Guys, if you see any anomaly, say something.
Spirits, can you hear us?
Yes.
What are you baking in here?
Ooh, bread.
Oh, wow, bread.
There's Skelly in there?
There's Skelly in there.
Oh my god.
Get out of the way.
And everyone died.
You died.
Oh man.
Okay.
You see, look, that actually is some of the spirits, because now my other flashlight's out there.
Oh, wait, never mind.
Oh, okay.
This is why we bring the spare, Mendoza.
This is why we bring the spare.
Ghosty, I got a question.
Mm-hmm.
What is your favorite place to haunt?
Like, if you guys pick, why are you haunted?
Um, I like to haunt people's homes because it's always stocked with food.
Are you raiding people's fridges like that?
That's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
I tend to do that.
If you steal on the Capri Suns?
If they have any, I definitely would take a Capri Sun.
I would too.
Wow, this area is so spooky looking.
Alright.
Welcome to the haunted sick bay.
Oh, it's the metal burner.
this is definitely where people have died oh whoa I go on with the flashlight on or just the red light just the red light actually the flashlight on in case we see something that's a great start here this is so scary I feel like you know how you have like other game devs coming here you need to have a horror game game devs come too.
Bring a phasmophobia or something?
Okay, that just turned off without me.
Oh my gosh!
Flashlights are really acting weird.
Yeah, my flashlights are acting up right now.
Dave, I told you this was the area that had the most activity gone.
Yeah, honestly, we just...
We got in here and suddenly flashlights started going crazy.
Uh-oh.
Crazy hop.
Oh my god!
I'm not even doing anything.
Yeah.
See?
I'm not even doing anything.
Whoa.
Even just the tools alone make it look so spooky.
It's Can you hear us?
Trick or treat.
Trick, smell my food.
Give me something.
If you don't, I don't care.
I'll pull down your underwear.
Is there any spirits living here still?
Hello, it's me and Minto.
I'm a ghost too.
Good morning.
Did you hear that?
Wait, what's that?
Sounds like uncle.
It's uncle grandpa.
It was uncle grandpa, right?
Uncle grandpa, can you hear us?
Hey, what's going on?
Good morning, Minto.
No bad morning, Minto.
You watch Minto streams.
Yeah, do.
This is great.
This is like the most EVP I've ever heard.
Uncle Grandpa, are you having a good day today?
Bad moment.
Uncle Grandpa, should we leave?
No, you can hang out with Pizza Steve.
Aw, he's nice.
Okay, thank you Uncle Grandpa.
Come on, man.
Oh my gosh, Pizza Steve.
Pizza Steve.
this is not like hers you can't really go oh the things i do for long
you're real you're real you're real no she's she's she's at home she's resting she's not here
someone asked have you ever had a stowaway or someone get lost on the ship before yeah i couldn't get lost before i can't believe that it's a big maze down here miss maybe you don't know your way it's catacombs what what do you do in that kind of situation well when you're wandering through the catacombs you get a half mask you put on your face and then you say the phantom of the alpha rise here tonight i could do that i could be the phantom of
a cosplay for your model and get like the half mask and all that stuff playing through.
Yeah, you could just have me in like the corner, like in the very bottom of the ship.
So that means you're going to do a cover of Music of the Night?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go through your toe of the knob.
Chad doesn't even know.
They're not theater kids.
They don't know.
They know.
Well, that's not creepy at all.
I didn't leave that door open.
Whoa!
Wait, actually?
Actually, it's supposed to be close.
Someone else?
Is anybody else on here?
The show?
Hello.
Do
you hear that?
No.
Someone just told us hello.
That was you, no?
me what that was you no that was you no wait you see that come from my perspective down down the hall i don't know if they could see it i don't see it here first camera move kind of center
standing in the back all the way wait Oh, I think I see, like, a figure on the left, no?
That's what we see right now, too.
Spirit, we mean you no harm.
Please stay here.
Thank you.
You are at rest.
Leave it be.
And let's quietly go up the stairs.
I thought you were saying hi because you were like, is anyone here?
I didn't turn on that light.
What?
Why is it getting so crazy?
This is the most intense tour I've done thus far.
The other ones, I was like, oh yeah, it's cool.
I'm in control.
So everyone having a good time?
Yeah!
Holy crap, my heart is thumping.
Oh my gosh.
Well, Miss Mint, if you will give my eulogy at my funeral, I would appreciate it.
Yeah, I'll be fine.
He lived as he died.
Definite.
I was a simple Jeff and I died a simple Jeff.
Are any questions people have?
Any questions you guys?
Any questions?
I'm waiting.
People are just doing 07.
Wait, someone said where's old Alan?
Who's that?
Oh, Mr. Cartwright?
Well, he's not a ghost yet.
Oh, what the hell?
Why would you ask that?
Mr. Cartwright, you were kidding.
Here, I thought it was a ghost.
It's just an old man.
someone asked what's your favorite plane it's not a spooky question but we can ask my favorite aircraft or plane in our collection aboard the ship uh let's do on the ship uh on the ship my favorite aircraft is actually right down there miss june who remembers miss june our hat will say hi to miss june when we pass by she's one of my favorite staff here My favorite aircraft overall,
though.
And I don't think I can answer this question because you know what, Miss Mint.
They will kill me.
Oh.
I love all jet girls equally.
You know that is my favorite above another.
There are many jets, but I like them all the same.
See?
Guys?
There, if...
If...
That's the safest answer possible.
Yeah, I think so.
You would get in trouble.
Spoken like a true manager.
Look, we love our jet girls.
There we go.
Ah.
Check out V-Fleet, you guys.
Actually, we rebranded.
Yeah.
Full rebrand, right?
What?
We are V-Fet now, apparently.
Oh.
I don't know how it happened.
But they did it.
The talents said they wanted it.
to be v feet and you gave me you gave me trouble for talking about the feet lockers i didn't make this choice it was just on brand this this this life didn't choose me i chose it Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi, Miss June.
Would you see you again?
I brought Minto back.
Yep.
I'm here to kiss you on the lips.
Yeah, you love kissing the hacks on the lips, don't you?
Yes.
Tari, if you can hear this, she just confirmed it.
That'll scare away any ghosts.
Yeah, ghosts are deathly afraid of Yuri.
Oh my gosh, I'm Yuri Manga!
Stay away, stay away!
Oh my god, that guy there scared them.
That scared me so bad.
Oh, that's just really sharp.
Spooked me.
Okay.
All right, since you've been here, Miss Smith, it's just a little thing here.
This is our newest aircraft to our collection.
This is the F-A-18C.
So this is Faye.
Well, this is Faye's cousin.
This aircraft is famous because it scored a mid-kill during the Persian Gulf War, one of the only aircraft to do so.
Wow!
Yep.
This was recently donated to the museum.
We are going to begin restoring her to a private commission.
Wow!
Pretty.
Are there any questions before we enter it?
Any questions again guys?
Feel free to always ask questions.
I'll try to ask when I can.
Spooky.
Spooky hallway.
Come on, let's go.
display the planes on the flight deck we have some aircraft that are on the
flight have you ever fallen through any hatches I have not fallen I almost did Oh.
Oh.
Why is the floor sticky?
Ew.
This could be ectoplasm, you think?
It could be.
Sorry, I'm dripping a little.
I'll mop it up.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
It's like sweat.
It's natural.
What?
I'm a ghost!
I can't do this man, I can't do it.
Lord Jesus, please forgive me.
Oh God, if you're a man, this mittel, but dear God.
My bad.
Thanks for the raid!
What?
The actual fudge!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
It's just ghost things.
Just ghosty things, you know?
I don't want to know about that.
I don't want to know what ghost be doing.
I don't want to know about what they're doing or whatever.
My bad.
I'll keep that to myself from now on.
Oh my gosh!
What?
I'm scared of women.
Scared of girls!
Don't be...
Actually, I'm kind of scared of women too.
I'm scared of girls.
Oh, I'm blocking.
My head's blocking it.
Sorry guys.
Got that lovely buzzing sound.
Alright, here we are.
Generators.
Are there any women ghosts here that we can run away from?
Hi.
Oh wait, yep, right, I forgot.
Did it always have a lady's bathroom or is that like a like a newer addition?
We have to be a museum, Ms. Mitchell.
Do
you have any ghosts that are like, you know, well known to like the team?
Like they have they have names?
Besides Fred, I guess?
I told you about Fred.
Maybe that's what we saw when we were on the back part of the ship.
Oh!
He was like, Do you know who I am?
Oh my gosh, please don't.
Please don't do that.
You're at home right now in your computer, and we are in the thick city.
If I die, you better write a nice apology letter to my mother.
No!
You'll be fine.
Remember this room?
This is where we summon the spirit bomb.
Ooh.
It looks big.
Wait, what is this room?
It's an angel room.
Oh.
Spirit, are you here?
Fred?
They're not followed us.
This is Jeff.
I need you no more.
Simply want to exploit you for content on the internet.
Someone asked, what makes a good haunted ship ghost?
Like, do you need to be military or be watery?
Yeah, what is a good, like, what's your ideal haunted ship ghost?
I don't think I have an idea.
I think I don't want to see no ghost, but I think I would say it's got to be some it's got to be somebody who has some sort of relation to the ship right
are we the only ones on the ship today right now the only two people on the ship right at this very moment oh camera name wow
oh spooky something
up there i don't know if i'll show you that
Oh, that end.
Oh.
Hey.
A door open?
Oh.
I don't think I can fit in there, Miss Minto.
I'm a little too big.
How often are you hitting your head on these ceilings?
Well, I can't remember my birthday, so that should tell you.
Yeah, that answers it.
That explains a lot, actually.
laugh my mom said I am super smart hello
down there hello good morning Minto boat goes binted boat goes binted boat goes binted I think if you say that enough times the ghosts will understand the joke boat goes binted boat goes bent in boat goes bent in
there's so many places to sleep on this boat
yeah i guess you could say they're laying around all over the place
good one not that fun not that oh miss merrick i did have a question for you i want to ask um so i was at off guy expo this past year right it's my first off guy oh um and you had a meet and greet well oh no was meet and greet it was with oshi spark and it was called a spit and greet yes what was that i i only saw a glimpse but i am curious what what what did so is this part of the haunted stories or i mean i'm just asking a question right now I needed to ask you.
I was going to DM it to you, but I'm just like, nah, she's busy, but you know, since we're here.
Right.
Yeah.
Um, so, uh, people would come, they would, they actually signed up for this and then they would say, oh, I came here to meet you and I would say, nice to meet you.
And then, um, at the end, I would just go, what do we?
and um okay tour's over no no no no you asked don't ask questions if you don't want to know the answer you know what you know what the v2 we're seeing it's crazy y'all i quit i'm done i ain't doing this no more shows over shows over shows over again just doing out the stream shows this is over
Back me up here, back me up here, Fred.
I'm going home.
You guys, I'm going home.
Y'all talk about spitting on people?
Your mama's told you don't spit on people.
I think V-feet would want to do that.
You know what the really sad part is, Miss Minto?
What?
More than likely, yes.
More than likely.
Yeah, I think so.
serious blue light yeah what is that
didn't you watch finding Nemo you don't go moving towards the blue light well actually I'm a ghost so I also shouldn't be going towards the light unless I want to you know yeah probably not someone asked is a true 300 people have passed away on the hornet yes it is that's a lot of people a lot of souls still hanging around still on duty yeah 300 ghosts it's crowded in here they having a ghost brave.
Now,
you know what they're dancing to Ms. Smith?
First I was afraid.
I was petrified.
I'm thinking I could never leave one by my side.
But then I spent so many nights thinking how I grew.
And I grew strong.
And I learned how to get along and now you're back.
From my space, I walk right here with that said look upon your face.
I should have changed as you were left.
I should have known the way to keep.
If I had known for just one second, you'd be back to follow me.
Now, now, now, go.
Walk out the door.
Just aren't around now.
You're not welcome anymore.
Aren't you the one who tried to hurt me with goodbye?
You thought I'd crumble.
Oh, now I lay down now.
I will survive.
Oh, if I come on, how to love, I know I will survive.
And if I get all my life to give, I got all my love to give.
Now I'll survive.
I will survive.
Yay!
Well, I'll take it.
Any questions, you laden?
Any questions, anybody?
Free concert.
Any weddings?
On the ship?
We do open up the ship for weddings, so people have gotten married here because we do act as a venue for different events, you know.
We do events like Kyrgyzstan, but like sometimes people like to rent us out for weddings, parties.
Matter of fact, there was a furry.
convention here, so we do just about everything.
Oh, furry convention!
So it was your first show, and uh...
Someone asked, what's the weirdest story you've ever heard?
It doesn't have to be paranormal, just weird.
Uh...
Cool.
I think the weirdest story I've heard
was...
Was...
Was when someone came aboard the ship and they lost their badge.
And a tradition they have aboard here is if you come aboard the ship and you're a staffer, voluntary, don't have their badge.
They give you a replacement badge, but you know where it is?
Where?
A guy with a paper bag on his head saying SS dummy.
Oh!
And I'm like, that's a...
You do that.
It's weird.
The second weirdest thing is when I became a staff member, that was pretty weird.
It was all downhill from there.
Oh, yeah, I believe that.
now you got you got furry conventions and anime conventions on here can you imagine what an anime convention like aircraft carrier yeah guys have you guys heard of carrier con 2026 baby but anyways miss met hack concludes the ghost tour we went about to every haunted area in the ship cover a lot of ground we lost our minds to brain rot so you know it was a good stream are there any questions any last questions you guys any last questions this was the death game for a limited time only like buzz light here here for here one moment but i'm not here for infinity but i'll be here for beyond oh gosh wait people are asking so many things hold on um oh someone said which ship do you think is more haunted the uss hornet or uss yorktown Ooh,
that's a good one.
So the newest, Yorktown is very haunted, definitely has its own stories.
The Hornet has a lot of its own stories as well.
The Hornet is as she is when she was decommissioned in 1970.
Yorktown had a little bit of changes to her.
So if we're talking about who has more paranormal activity, I would say it's very, very close.
What I say the Hornet is probably more authentic, so you're going to see probably undisturbed wrestling places.
Probably so.
But, you know, not trying to be biased or anything, but just, you know, the same.
But love the Usset Yard town.
They have a wonderful crew, and they do their own ghost tours as well.
So make sure to go support them, guys, if you're on the East Coast.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Um, someone asked, how is V-Fleet going?
Anything you want to hype up?
Beefly, it's going really well, guys.
Thank you very much.
Girls, you know, we've had new talents come, and it's been really great.
It's been a lot of fun.
And we're taking such a big stride in that we're actually producing our first ever IRL concert, similar to off-season live Miss Smith, called Boat Goes Vincent.
I'm dead serious with you.
That is the ripple.
Dead.
But we're producing our own first concert.
It's going to be held at the USS Iowa Museum in San Pedro, California.
It's actually going to be a fundraiser for the USS Iowa.
We're doing in collaboration with the museum, and your ticket, 100% of the proceeds, are going to the USS Iowa.
Iowa will be doing the ticketing, so it's going straight to them.
And your ticket counts as a donation.
So that's something really cool that you could do.
Off your taxes, saying.
We're excited to be collaborating with the USS Iowa.
They have a wonderful crew down there.
It's going to be over ALA weekend.
Los Angeles so on feel free to come by it's gonna be a great concert can't talk about the lineup just yet can't do that otherwise some of the staff who are watching your stream right now are going to kill me in discord afterwards so but I will say it is very very high and you know obviously on the hornet side we're gearing up for a lot of great events coming up we have our New Year's Eve the gallop that's coming up here what's that uh that is well it's new year's evening this minute yeah it would be January 31st right right sorry it would be December to see I'm messing up on days off see this is the ghosty brain rot that's consuming me right now yeah yeah it's okay you had a busy night hey that minty brain rot is contagious man it's contagious contagious like a disease it's a virus it's a virus but we're going viral oh subscribe like and comment on the video well we got some cool stuff coming here up where the ship carrier con 2026 in case you guys didn't see it's actually two days now
we're going from march 20 uh well march 21st and 22nd but ocean on deck the concert we have will be on the 20th can't talk about that just yet really can't talk I really want to talk about it, huh?
Huh, man, huh, those people really want to talk about it.
But we can't just yet.
But a lot of great stuff is happening.
And this year's fundraiser is going to be amazing because we're raising money to increase the Hornets accessibility, new ADA accessibility, repairs to our brows, but also elevators to help get people to, especially with wheelchair accessibility.
So if you've been in the Hornet, you know it's very historical.
We have to build around it.
So we are looking at different ways to make the ship more accessible.
uh your ticket this year and obviously any donations you do or contributions will go towards making the ship more accessible for future generations to come so that's what we're doing there beefly's doing well um and again we all appreciate you guys to support very much about these museums folks i can't never tell you enough these places are magical um obviously a little scary a little scary but that's part of the charm right yeah i can't believe we got so like the the flashlights and And then we saw that thing down the hall.
I know, I had, like, two flashlights the whole time.
I was thinking, well, I mean, it kept turning on.
So it tells me, hey, that's the experience.
Ghosts passing.
Freaky.
Sorry, it caused such a disruption.
I know.
Hey, that's the most paranormal activities happened with you thus far.
So just saying.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
There was also, like, the banging and everything.
Wow.
What was going on?
We saw Fred.
Yeah.
Wild, man.
freaky and it feels like the end of a blues poof episode so what did we learn i know my little recap oh yeah uncle grandpa even came and gave a little dude okay uncle grandpa was crazy he was all like good morning you think that means she's died he's dead now yes uncle grandpa is dead and i don't want to talk about how i know that it's just the creator posted never mind i don't want talk about that this is real lore wait is a wild place and the uncle grandpa creator is a wild person what what tweet okay i'm gonna look into this now no don't don't look at the old grandpa tweet no no okay all right i won't i won't go thanks thanks yes yes uncle grandpa got canceled Not like that,
but like the show, I guess.
Oh.
I don't know.
Uncle Grandpa might have gotten killed.
Put longer is crazy.
I mean, who knows?
But anyways, are there any other questions?
Any last questions, you guys?
Any last questions?
I thought I'd get to deathgate for a minute.
So let's go see if he wants to be back.
People are saying thanks for the tour.
Is Fred Haas style?
huh it's very hostile yeah no it's not hostile he's just he's just hanging around he's just doing his thing he's chill he's chill hey he's a chill guy
not the pan down oh my god
got an ace combat question what's your favorite have you played any of them i think i've you this before yes i've played ace combat seven oh okay so that should be your favorite then uh i i guess so i guess it's my favorite because it's the only one to play metal gear metal gear series right now you know you inspired me this man i'm getting through it's not just about center armstrong no nano machines uh i used to you know i used to work college ball wait what which which one are you playing uh i'm trying to remember i don't know i take gaps okay okay you can't tell me that i'm gonna quiz you i got my job and then i got vtuber thing it's a lot misfits okay okay i'll let you off easy this time i'll tell you when i when i check the title i'll tell you i'll text you okay yeah yeah yeah send me a dm me tell me everything send me everything's like five paragraphs worth like need like an essay of everybody who starts Metal Gear and their experience and their thoughts and everything.
Oh my gosh, so it's just going to be like this much, I'll be like, what I learned about playing Metal Gear is, what I learned about playing Metal Gear is.
I mean, it's like, like, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
Yeah.
And some of these, and some of these, and finish.
The boom.
It'll just say Metal Gear.
No, I'll just say no.
It'll be like a really, really well-illustrated though.
Yeah, okay.
Yes, exactly.
Well, thank you again for the ghost tour.
This was so spooky and fun.
Absolutely.
Yeah, I really appreciate you taking me out again.
And my chat, too.
This meant it's always a pleasure.
It's always wonderful.
We love having you here aboard the ship.
We're such a great supporter.
We're very grateful to you here at the museum.
I personally, very grateful to you.
You know, along with Miss Lisa, you were the second tour that I had given here aboard the ship.
It's really blessed my life in the sense that I love showing new people the ship.
You know, the VTuber tour has been really great.
You know, everybody can appreciate this place.
And so I'm very glad I've been able to help contribute to keeping the ship's legacy alive, but also at the same time, helping people like you learn a little bit about this place and learn about the people behind it.
So, you know, thank you very much.
Blessing my life.
I very much appreciate you for that.
And, you know, it's been great.
Thank you.
Tell Miss Debbie I said hi.
I will tell Miss Debbie you said hello.
I will tell Miss Debbie.
That's the thing, folks.
You guys come to the museum.
Ask for Miss Debbie.
Learn her story.
She's a great lady here aboard the ship.
Father was on the ship.
And she does a lot of restoration work.
Kind old lady.
And she is amazing.
So make sure to ask Miss Debbie.
Yeah.
Thank you, Jeff.
That's it.
Thank you.
All right, folks.
We'll catch you later, okay?
Okay.
Bye-bye.
that's me
yay whoa oh you know I expected spooky but I didn't expect like the banging was so scary and like what I was freaky and if he really didn't say hi who did
the area with the red light was so cool it was i want to i want to go do a ghost tour for real on the ship i want to go i want to go i will someday i wish that i think the only thing is i wish so you didn't see the face was it not the was it not the devil thing that he showed us it wasn't that I think the only thing that I wish was you know obviously this is not Gabe's fault but the discord noise you know what's the word noise canceling nah we were gaslighting Oh,
hey, good fan of ship tours and ghost tours.
Thank you, Vinto.
Of course.
Yeah, if only we didn't have the noise canceling so that it could be like we could hear more, you know?
It's a great tradition.
Please keep doing it.
Of course.
Maybe one day it could be me, you know?
I could be the one walking around and with my camera and everything so that whatever is going on, caught, then you guys hear it too and everything.
And then I wouldn't be scared, maybe.
Maybe.
Marco, thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you guys so much for all the donos and the gifted.
And I saw somebody raided and everybody donated a lot.
I didn't want to distract so much from Jeff Gabe talking.
So, um, you would definitely be scared.
No, I wouldn't.
No, I'm...
Thanks for the fun Tormento.
Thank you.
That was so much fun.
Sorry, is his name Jeff or Gabe?
That's a great question.
So last time... What?
Everybody start calling him Jeff.
I think he made a joke about being named Jeff.
And everyone thought his name was Jeff.
And then he was just like...
No, my name's actually Gabe.
Okay.
He said, hi.
My name is Jeff, ma'am.
He introduced himself as Jeff.
So it was that.
But no, his name is Gib.
But we call him Jeff Gib.
Or Gib.
Or, no, not Gib.
We call him Jeff.
Surely Minto won't be scared.
Thank you for the fun Tori Minto.
Is Jeff single?
I think he answered this last time too.
Wait, but it's been a year.
again for you guys sorry but you could always go to the hornet try not to harass him too much there's also carrier con bivikor thanks for that five gift and thank you you could always be like is there a jeff aka gabe around here and then and then you know ask him you know you should I shouldn't just say,
like, hey, are you single?
You should, like, kind of rizze him up a little.
I cannot believe nobody has made a five booms at Costco yet.
That's been in my brain this whole time.
Five booms at Costco.
I can't.
How has that not been done yet?
Synapse!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Lucky, thank you so much the gifted i have a question i've seen so many people with with the what's it called the microsoft paperclip guy has their profile picture why why is everybody getting their their profile picture to the little guy clippy you know someday you should advise him to put the big jpeg dog card for a nice halloween it was i don't think it would spook anybody I think everybody would be like,
dog!
If you do an IRL, won't the perspective be too low?
Hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey!
Oh!
Oh, I see!
Oh, okay.
I've seen so many people with it.
I was like, I thought they...
Maybe people were like, bring Clippy back.
I didn't know anything.
I don't know anything, you guys.
I don't know anything.
Clippy.
Bring Clippy back.
Or maybe not.
I don't know.
Anyway.
I hope you guys enjoyed the tour.
Boo.
Ah!
Why would you...
Why would you do that?
How about the IQ?
This is so funny and the BGM made this extra spooky.
Enjoyed it a lot.
I'm glad!
I'm glad, I'm glad!
About right of maintenance and having infinite subscription service.
No, I get it, I get it.
I respect it, I respect it.
PGM was good?
Let me know, I mean, let me help you.
It was one of my best friends and fellow whispers.
Birthday!
Happy birthday, Dylan!
Wait, there were some other birthdays I missed.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
There were some people's birthdays.
I'm so sorry.
It's hard during, like, this kind of stream to catch you guys, you know?
Especially because it's like you don't want to interrupt the tour.
So, hold on.
I saw it.
Super chat.
Oh, good.
Where'd it go?
Oh, my first birthday is a wisp!
Coral!
Happy birthday.
I hope you're still here.
Zenfus, welcome back.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I think I think that was the only one that I noted.
Okay.
So here, I'll change it from the spookier music to a...
That was so spooky!
Ah, I really want to go...
Last year, I went on a ghost tour with some friends.
It's kind of funny doing it as a ghost because you're like...
Hey!
Hi!
but this makes me wish that I had gone on one this year too dang oh well yeah I got the inside information you're like what's up guys I don't haunt this place but um cool nice nice house you got going on here Noah's also bookie events birthday merch orders ending tomorrow yes they do my birthday merch ends tomorrow pre-orders end tomorrow uh 11 59 PST if you want to get your order in tomorrow is the last day ah raviya thank you so much thank you for oh thank you for the dono thank you for the info
now so if you Don't want the FOMO.
It's not coming back.
So, last chance.
Got mine.
Thank you.
Got the plushie.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Got my set and extra shirt.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
So when you go ghost hunting, how do you prevent the equipment from picking up you or your EVP?
Oh, that's a great question.
Honestly, I don't use the EVP because of that.
like and also if i'm trying to do or not evp oh i thought you i thought oh i was thinking of um emf my bad um for evp when i do evp okay it's like kind of like when you're a ghost and like someone's doing an evp you kind of like have like this weird draw to like say something you know you're just like i feel compelled to speak so i have to try really hard not to speak you know I have to be like
you know so I try to basically um like look at the y'all yop control you should visit the USS Alabama in Mobile sometime she's in great shape and there's an aircraft museum they have F-14 and B-52 whoa even some tanks whoa is this so bad that I like want to go and cosplay Metal Gear.
So like one of these places.
As who?
Ryden?
Maybe.
Eeeee!
Wei Eee would be really good probably.
Mei Ling?
Wait, that'd be kind of cute too.
Minto Ryden would go home.
Which website is the birthday merch on?
I will link it.
Duh.
That's where you can get the birthday merch from!
Exploding Cat!
Welcome to the bamboo ship.
Thank you.
Got the plushie in time.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Need to go to USS Missouri and Hawaii for a little bit.
true true true true actually I'm gonna make a tweet right now about my merch and then I'll wait I'm also gonna put it I gotta make a tweet wait oh tweet then also I gotta put it on my screen tomorrow for tomorrow my brain is everywhere wait where's my there it is
wondering if the reality trim on your uniform is yellow or is it actually gold like gold like made of gold so happy happy early halloween happy happy early halloween made of gold did you think i am a king you think i have that money um last tomorrow is the last day to pre-order 11 59 p.m pst
Don't miss out.
Exclamation point, exclamation point, exclamation point.
Ghost emoji.
Exclamation point emoji.
Guys, sometimes I wish I could change my Oshi mark.
Sometimes I want to change it to like a ghost in a box.
Or maybe a ghost in an exclamation point.
I just make Metal Gear by branding.
You have a heart of gold, so...
Oh my gosh.
I meant the color.
It's like...
Yellow gold.
You can do yellow.
Or you can do gold.
Another's fine.
Okay, hold on.
Don't miss out.
Post.
Okay.
Your phone should be buzzing right now.
You have me on tweet.
Notifications on!
You saw it, you saw it, you know it, you know it, you saw it!
You said, oh my gosh!
That's...
That's, that's it!
How do you know?
Called out.
Like, like the tweet.
Thanks for the merch reminder, grab some extra plushies!
Oh my gosh, please no.
My tests weren't really good on Monday.
I got an...
What an idea!
I have 200!
Wait, are you actually smart?
I knew you could do it!
Thank you again for the good luck.
Beam yourself!
Oh, cool!
You didn't need it.
You didn't need it, Evan.
It was all inside you.
You did that.
You.
Yeah, congrats!
Guys, this whole time I've been having to pee.
I don't have to pee really bad.
I think I should go.
I've been- Wait, how do you become a VTuber?
Just a curious question.
How do you?
Um...
Well, I died.
So it's a little different for me.
Wait, why are you guys sending Super Chat?
Stop, I haven't left yet.
Um...
Hey, you just start.
I think that's kind of just what I did, is I just started streaming.
I don't think you have to die for it to...
for it to...
work.
i think usually you need a tragic backstory mine's not try well i died i don't think that's so tragic though i think stop it you guys i finished work early and i get to watch some ah spooky me though today is a good day we busy g thank you hope you're having a great time people people Princess.
What is that?
What do you...
Why am I people, people, princess?
I died of Ligma.
That's my death of Ligma.
Wait, can I...
Wait, I want to recreate the Zam.
She's freaky.
Wait.
How did I do that?
Zam.
She is freaky.
ZAM
ZAM Go girl go Don't leak Do you think he was upset about me saying that Thank you for today Listening to you while dealing with hotel troubles Are you okay, not me
Hotel troubles?
That doesn't sound so good Happy Hallows E!
Can't believe tomorrow's Halloween I still don't have an idea of what I'm doing tomorrow.
It's pretty bad.
My brain has been like half stuff I need to do.
Like that I cannot say.
And half US Idol Festival.
And barely any space for Halloween activity.
That's like your day.
Don't remind me.
Oh, well, it's like last year I had my, oh my gosh, wait, tomorrow it will be one year since my 3.0.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
So, last year I had that.
And then earlier this month, I had my birthday live, so it felt like, you know, a lot of stuff already happened, you know.
Takizotaki-kyo!
Thank you.
3.0 anniversary.
debut stream watchalong I have some ideas for what I want to do tomorrow I'm just trying to think of what I can implement
yes yes yes it's just like I said my brain finally got my mint happy coat thank you for buying it thank you 4.0 she can't stop changing I transcend every year
yeah it might be a little more chill tomorrow but i think that's okay too there's always gonna there's it's Halloween there's gonna be a lot of a lot of uh spooky happenings going on so especially for holidays obviously i don't want to not do something but i try to do a little i guess shorter of something so that you can hop around to all that's going on and stuff yeah twinkle dog seance
just a little shum shum but it's been really busy for me lately I'm so sorry guys where my brain has been seriously focused on a million things at once but that's why I like doing game streams so much because I'm just like, I focus on game and I don't have to think about anything else.
It's actually a break for me of thinking about other things.
But it should come down a little bit eventually.
But yeah, thank you guys for the tour.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I hope you enjoyed all the spooky...
Spookiness that happened too.
It was fun.
Thank you for the fun spooky stream.
And...
Chill will be fun tomorrow.
I'm going to go slice up...
What are you slicing up a wisp for?
But I do think that...
You guys should check out...
The Hornet?
V-Fleet, CarrierCon.
since they've been so awesome to give these tours and everything, take time out of, you know, Gabe Jeff has taken time out of his night even to give us a tour, so.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
To see what's inside.
Goop!
Yeah!
I'll be going on a flight later for vacation and bringing my Mito pleasure with me!
If I can make it for tomorrow's dream.
Jay, have a great vacation, have a safe flight!
Take lots of pictures and post them so I can see.
Otsu!
Mito, everybody!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you when I see you next!
Jokes on Twitter.
Okay, I will check it out.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Oh, yes.
Welcome back.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
I think
isn't Doobie streaming?
I think I will try to raid her if it lets me.
Let's see.
Redirect to Doobie.
A doobster.
I was watching her play with Limu and Saba earlier, so it was cute.
Okay, bye-bye.
Have fun.
See you.